Jordan Rogers ex puts him on a blast I
mean to be honest it was really hard The
Bachelorette winner dated personal
trainer Brittany Farrar before joining
the show she says they were together for
nearly four years and now she's calling
him a quote prolific liar and cheater
Brittany posted a lengthy note to
Instagram Thursday night explaining a
lie she wanted to share this information
to get her side of the story out there
she then posted a video she says is it
proof jordan cheated here it is a
receipt for flower delivery to a woman
who is not Brittany Brittany said Jordan
sent to the flowers to a girl he met
while working as an extra on pitch
perfect to he's in the background of
this scene Brittany says she and Jordan
were still very much a couple at that
point and that she has a text messages
to prove it she wrote in the caption
quote if you weren't ready to be
truthful about your life then you
shouldn't have gone on a reality show
jordan has yet to respond to Brittany's
allegations but has denied cheating in
the past